[音楽]
何だろう
崙亂カドランだんだんらんらんらんらーん
[音楽]
ん
ううぅううええええ
ですえっこれがねとねぇねぇぜ
今や起きたね花火ぶっ放す税
誰だ
を
me
[音楽]
a
いやぁああああああ
なんだよこれ
10月ねーのかよは
強化たねー
[音楽]
すがー
ああああああ
えっ
う
me
はへ
大丈夫だ
俺を悪い奴じゃない
お前の味方なん
大丈夫大丈夫だ
俺は何もしない
大丈夫
信じてくれ
大丈夫だ
大丈夫
よすいい子だ
はっはっは
あっはぁ
あ
俺の名前は初め
君の名前は
ベンガベルてぃんがーれるって言うのか
素敵な名前だ
君はどこから来たんだい
あーごめん
言いたくないことは言わなくていいから
大丈夫だ
君は
住むところはあるのかい
そうか
あ
だったら
家に住むのはどうかな
[音楽]
持っていた
持って
こうして俺と店ガーベルの生活が始まった
ん
最初は10ガーベルも地球に馴染んでないせいかいろいろ迷惑をかけてたら徐々に子宮
の生活に慣れていったんだこいつとがもう仲良し
フォルト点がベルは最高のパートナーさ
[音楽]
でも俺はティンカーベルが他の人間にバレることを
恐れていた
[音楽]
ぽっと
ブー
ここなら大丈夫かな
もういいぞ
よしすっこコーナーが大丈夫だなぁ
tenga ベル
大事な話があるんだ
君はこの追求の生き物じゃない
もし君がその姿なの誰かに見られると
君は変な大人たちに怪しい緊急所に連れて行かれるかもしれないんだ
だから点がベル
守備は他の人がいるときは絶対その姿にならないでくれ
わかったかい
tenga ベル
ヤバス
e 9打点がベル他の人間が来たら趣味やすぐに点がの形に変わるんだわかったね
venga
一時だったってがっ
10がー
ゼンガー
ています
tan
テンガンベルはますます地球の生活になじんできた
他の地球人がきたらすぐに点がモードに変身できるし
[音楽]
今のこいつとだったら
外に大勢かけすることもできるのだ
そういつしか俺と点がベルは最高の立つになっていて masa
もう俺はこいつなしだと生きていけねぇ
[音楽]
そしてある日の夜10がメールはこいつの過去を例に教えてくれた
こいつはトランスフォーマーの仲間でベストロンという悪の組織に追われている身
らしい
俺がなんとかしてこいつを救いたい
だが笑
事件は起きてしまうペンガードもな連れて来たーー
でんがぁ
てがー
てがでんがぁでんなぁんなぁ目がぁてがーてガーってなぁ
tender
ペンなぁ
待てよ
まさか
[音楽]
あいつが話していたら
悪の組織
ペストリー
連れてかれたぁぁぁ
嘘だろう
テンガンベル
ってまぁペンがー
があった
どうしてますかじいさん
わけじゃここに前がなかったああ
気持ちよかった捨てちゃったーーーーせがー
[音楽]